we know why kids don't learn it's either
poverty
low attendance negative peer influences
we know why but one of the things that
we never discuss or we rarely discuss
is the value and importance of human
connection
relationships i have had classes that
were so low
so academically deficient that i cried
i wondered how am i going to take this
group
in nine months from where they are to
where they need to be
how do i raise the self-esteem of a
child in his academic achievement at the
same time
one year i came up with a bright idea i
told all my students
you were chosen to be in my class
because i am the best teacher and you
are the best students
they put us all together so we could
show everybody else how to do it
one of the students said really
i said really and i gave him a saying to
say i am
somebody i was somebody when i came i'll
be a better somebody when i leave
i am powerful and i am strong i deserve
the education that i get here
i have things to do people to impl press
and places to go
and they said yeah you say it long
enough
it starts to be a part of you
both my parents were educators my
maternal
grandparents were educators for years i
watched my mother take the time at
recess to review
go on home visits in the afternoon buy
combs and brushes and peanut butter and
crackers to put in a desk drawer for
kids that
needed to eat and a washcloth and some
soap for the kids too it didn't smell so
good see it's hard to teach kids who
stink
years later after she retired i watched
some of those same kids
come through and say to her you know
miss walker you made a difference in my
life
you made it work for me you made me feel
like i was somebody
when i knew at the bottom i wasn't
and i want you to just see what i've
become and when my mama died two years
ago at 92
there were so many former students at
her funeral it brought tears to my eyes
not because she was gone but because she
left a legacy
of relationships that could never
disappear
every child deserves a champion an adult
who will never give
up on them who understands the power of
connection
and insists that they become the best
that they can possibly be
is this job tough you bet you oh god
you betcha but it is not
impossible we can do this we're
educators we're born to make a
difference
thank you so much